c'est le journal
parce que c'est un bon coin parce que
les gens
à côté comment tu vas vendre
les gens ils viennent pour acheter les
journaux
et oui mais c'est pas ta place
vous pouvez vendre des journaux oui
c'est pas dur il faut les gens ils
demandent le journal et je leur donne
ils me donnent des sous c'est pas du
tout
200 m pour vente 200 m oui monsieur et
ça fait pas 200 là
toi tu entends pas passer pour un con ou
quoi non je te dis maintenant
facture de quoi les journaux ah non je
les ai trouvés sur un kiosque le soir
des trucs qu'on a trouvé en fait du jour
donc il faut que je les vendeur sinon
demain je pourrai plus les vendre vous
allez les vendre ailleurs sinon moi
j'appelle les flics
je lui ai dit une fois ça va alors
maintenant vous voulez là-bas vous voyez
très gentil avec moi de 50 m 10 plus
haut les vents c'est son problème
posez-le et on va faire 50 mètres et je
vous le vends à 2 francs 50
c'est à vous de choisir s'il y a
quelqu'un qui me demande un journal que
j'ai pas tout de suite je le balance
devant chez moi les journaux que j'ai
pas moi je dis aux gens à demander à la
dame parce que non vous comprenez ce que
je vous dis non c'est n'importe qui fait
ça et où je vais moi j'ai plus qu'à
faire mes boutiques
ah bah oui viens fermer parce que comme
ça moi je pourrais vendre les miens plus
[Musique]